good morning you guys beautiful shot as
we look over the city right now looks a
little bit hazy out there
because we've still got a little bit of
dust suspended and we've got a little
moisture in the air too the system is
working its way out we did get a little
bit of rain last night it was around
between nine and eleven o'clock
henderson area picked up about four
hundredths of an inch collagen 95 50
degrees right now in downtown henderson
54 in green valley lots of 50's this
morning we're cooler overall plus we've
got northwest wind that we're dealing
with today so that makes the
temperatures feel even chillier
mountains edge you're at 44 seven hills
at 43 centennial hills at 47. look at
those 20s up at kyle canyon we did pick
up a little bit of snow maybe an inch or
so that's about it but you could see up
there at the webcam i've been looking at
lee canyon they've got a little dusting
up there 49 in boulder city 34 at indian
springs just updated these numbers 43 in
parum with a little bit of breeze there
not much wind at all in laflin though at
50 degrees and we're looking at 20s up
there in ely as well as caliani this
morning so here's our low pressure
system 54 right now in l.a so a parade
this morning at 11 a.m down at usc
campus
temperatures should be in
close to 60 degrees they're looking for
highs in the mid 60s today around l.a so
not those 80s like they had for the
super bowl we're looking at this low
pressure that will continue to move into
the rockies today and then the central
plains by tonight and tomorrow there is
snow across the intermountain west kind
of chilly there but warmer air is being
pulled up as you can see the
temperatures increasing over the
southern plains texas oklahoma arkansas
and louisiana that's the strike zone for
unfortunately for severe weather
and that's probably going to start
happening tonight into tomorrow with the
outbreak of thunderstorms from the clash
of our cold system as it pulls away from
us now with a little bit of rain and
snow still left in arizona this morning
and then exiting pretty quickly through
the day so we'll be left with some
pretty good sunshine today those
northwest winds about 25 miles an hour
for many areas today staying breezy even
tonight and into thursday temperatures
right around normal that will warm up a
little bit as we head into the
president's day weekend 71 by sunday
late clouds ahead of another chilly
system by president's day we're looking
at another chance for some valley
showers gusty winds and highs that drop
to the 50's by tuesday wednesday so hey
don't count winter out it's not over yet
nope
okay we're all good